il y à une personne ici dans l'équipe
qui est sorti avec une star
internationale
je vous le dis ça n'est pas de ce côté
non alors c'est de ce côté francesca
vous défie ce cas est sorti avec une
star internationale ou quand je vous dis
c'est pour moi une des plus grandes
stars mondiales ce poulain c'est un
sportif et c'est trouver de qui il
s'agit 20h12 vous avez une minute pour
vous avec qui elle a eu une aventure
oui je voulais a privilégié le ronfleur
qui m'a poucave parce que j'ai dit qu'à
une seule personne
à votre avis qui sait on m'a chrono une
minute c'est qu'elle est déjà venu sur
ce plateau non formule 1 il l'informé
l'un d'entre eux voleurs n'ont pas
football des messages laissés l'enquète
basket oui américain oui j'ordonne
michael jordan
non michael jordan et rieuse michael
jordan les fonds amassés
car elle est l ap thomas des chicago
bulls est apparemment elle a enlevé le
chicago elle avec les bulls
[Applaudissements]
nikon s'il vous plaît est ce que vous
êtes sorti avec lui il ya eu un truc
quand vous êtes pécheresse que vous avez
galoche est-ce que vous lui avez mis la
main pas dit non à drôle et combien de
temps est-ce que vous l'avez donné les
noms c'était il ya longtemps je tiens à
dire parce qu'il n'était pas en couple
là comme moi non plus d'accord très bien
armés et bien que et donc faisant ils
seraient rencontrés c'était au café de
l'homme je travaillais pour une chaîne
nrj 12
voilà reportages et lui il est venu pour
son équipementier à l'époque et il avoue
y avait plein de filles autour de lui et
en fait il pas elle est fille parlait
pas anglais et comme c'est la chance de
parler anglais suis venu pour traduire
et du coup voilà quoi est donc arrêté
comment s'est passée il a pris mon nom
mais sur place un homme allégée du coup
ils ont besoin de savoir où on est on
est toujours au café de l'homme et après
on est sorti dans la boîte de nuit qui
était le vip à l'époque sur les champs
elysées à l'eau chaude badraoui du
déclassement de rentrer dans les détails
évidemment c'est quoi il n'y a pas de
moment je parle du progrès un raconte
tout sinon je balance vraiment
amis je me suis confié je me suis dit ne
me balan sera pas ah oui j